[Música]
y
este hombre que veis en pantalla es omar
suleimán uno de los imanes más
influyentes de los estados unidos en
este vídeo dice que francia es el
epicentro de la islamofobia en europa
acusa a macrón y a todas las
instituciones francesas de hostigar a
las comunidades musulmanas según este
hombre francia es el laboratorio de
pruebas de todas las políticas para
oprimir a los musulmanes
mientras tanto erdogán en turquía ha
llegado a proponer un boicot contra
todos los productos franceses y algo
parecido ha dicho el presidente de
pakistán porque de repente tantos
líderes islámicos odian a francia la
razón es lo que el propio presidente
francés emmanuel matrón llama la lucha
contra el separatismo islámico a estas
alturas parece evidente que francia
tiene un problema con el gran radical y
macrón ha dejado claro que el problema
no
es el islam en sí sino el radicalismo
sin embargo porque hay tantos líderes
islámicos que se dan por aludidos qué
problema tiene francia con el islam
radical en este vídeo te lo vamos a
explicar
[Aplausos]
[Música]
el 16 de octubre del año 2020 un
profesor de un instituto francés samuel
para ti fue decapitado por uno de sus
alumnos el asesino era un chico de 18
años que se había ofendido cuando su
profesor mostró unas caricaturas de
mahoma en clase para hacer un debate
sobre la libertad de expresión
ah
para que os hagáis una idea desde el año
2015 los terroristas islámicos han
asesinado a 250 personas en francia eso
incluye a los propios autores de estas
caricaturas de mahoma claramente francia
tiene un problema con el islam radical y
no esto no es algo que preocupe
únicamente a la extrema derecha el 89
por ciento de los franceses de todas las
ideologías consideran que el terrorismo
islámico es uno de los problemas más
terribles a los que se enfrenta el país
y ojo esto no significa que todos los
musulmanes sean terroristas ni muchísimo
menos ni siquiera que todos los que
estén pidiendo boicots contra francia lo
sean sin ir más lejos ese señor que
sabía al principio de este vídeo está
amenazado de muerte por el dais
[Música]
para que sabes me ve a otros países como
alemania o países bajos también tienen
grandes comunidades musulmanas pero los
casos de francia y bélgica son
especialmente problemáticos pensad que
no sólo hablamos de atentados
terroristas ciudades como parís o
marsella tienen barrios enteros donde
solo se atreve a entrar la policía en
algunos casos podríamos hablar de todo
un estado paralelo en el seno de la
sociedad francesa comunidades
radicalizadas profesores que no se
atreven a hablar libremente en los
colegios públicos y mujeres que no
pueden vestir como quieran cuando salen
por la calle la decapitación de samuel
para ti ha sido la gota que ha colmado
el vaso y el presidente macro no ha
dicho basta
[Música]
macro lanza una campaña contra el
separatismo islámico en las comunidades
musulmanas este anuncio ha desatado una
oleada de odio anti francés en todo el
mundo musulmán los países del golfo
están organizando boicots contra los
productos franceses y el presidente de
turquía tanto como el de pakistán han
pedido a sus ciudadanos que eviten
comprar los productos franceses
[Música]
algunos líderes religiosos han llegado a
comparar a macrón con hitler o con
narendra modi ella se lo que estaréis
pensando muchos la comparación no tiene
ningún sentido francia ha dicho que
quiere acabar con el islam radical es
decir contra el terrorismo islámico no
contra toda la religión islámica había
hablado de cerrar todas las mezquitas ni
de deportar a todos los musulmanes ni
nada remotamente parecido sin embargo la
pregunta la auténtica pregunta es que
francia tiene más problemas con el
radicalismo islámico que cualquier otro
país europeo que quiere hacer macrón
para solucionarlo y por qué tantos
líderes islámicos se han puesto en su
contra hoy vamos a responder a estas
preguntas pero antes vamos a ver un poco
de historia
eres
bien se llama a cnet los años 50 y 60
fueron la época dorada de francia y qué
pasa cuando la economía de un país crece
como la espuma pues que de repente las
empresas reciben a los inmigrantes con
los brazos abiertos y de dónde venían
los inmigrantes franceses pues de las
colonias francesas del norte de áfrica
países como argelia o túnez enviaban a
millones de hombres a trabajar a las
fábricas de renault o 'the fall'
hablamos de gente que hablaba francés
como lengua materna se llamaban pierre o
jean marie y se casaban con mujeres
francesas en otras palabras que se
integraban al completo sin embargo todo
cambió en el año 1973
exacto 1973 es el año de la crisis del
petróleo una crisis que adopto
especialmente a francia el paro subió y
todas esas empresas que recibían a los
inmigrantes con los brazos abiertos
empezaron a despedir gente
[Música]
los inmigrantes dejaron de llegar a
francia y entonces es cuando el gobierno
francés sacó esta ley que en principio
parece muy razonable pero que tuvo unas
consecuencias muy importantes
en el año 1978 francia aprobó la ley de
reunificación familiar
esta ley permitía que los inmigrantes
franceses recién nacionalizados se
trajeran a sus familias de sus países de
origen esto llevó a una nueva oleada de
inmigrantes también venían de países
como francia argelia marruecos pero ya
no eran hombres en edad de trabajar sino
sus familiares por supuesto esta
política tiene toda la lógica del mundo
y diréis pero todo esto que tiene que
ver con el radicalismo islámico pues
tiene una influencia muy importante
pensando bien antes los inmigrantes que
llegaban no tenían más remedio que
integrarse en el país es decir hacer
amigos pareja y vida francesa sin
embargo a partir de los años 70 estos
inmigrantes ya podían casarse con
mujeres argelinas mujeres que se
quedaban en casa y cuidaban de los hijos
cada vez había menos matrimonios mixtos
y los hijos de estos inmigrantes
inmigrantes que se llamaban pie 'hoy en
madrid'
ahora se llamaban ahmed hassan
por supuesto esto no tiene por qué tener
ningún problema cada uno puede llamarse
como quiera pero si no sirve de
indicador de cómo esos argelinos y
tunecinos de segunda generación
empezaban a tener su propia cultura
distinta del resto de la sociedad
francesa y esto explica que los primeros
debates sobre el uso del hijab en
lugares públicos no se dieran en los
años 60 sino en 1989 pero esperad un
momento porque hasta la fecha francia
todavía no tenía un problema con el
radicalismo islámico que el problema
comienza a finales de los años 90 y
diréis qué pasa en esos momentos pues a
partir de ese momento es cuando francia
empieza a perder competitividad frente
al mercado global
os lo hemos explicado aquí en visual
político en un vídeo de hace varios años
que os dejo en la descripción desde el
año 2000 las exportaciones netas de
francia no han dejado de bajar mientras
alemania se ha convertido en toda una
potencia industrial global francia lleva
en declive económico durante todo el
siglo 21 conclusión
parís que es la ciudad más rica de
francia tiene un paro estructural del 8
por ciento el paro juvenil ha llegado al
19 por ciento ya que no adivinan quién
es el grupo más afectado por estos
niveles de paro exacto los descendientes
de estos inmigrantes argelinos pierre y
hamadi encontraron trabajo en renault
pero sus hijos y sus nietos a mehdi
hasan están en el paro
[Música]
pero ojo porque aquí no termina el drama
como sabéis francia es famoso por tener
las regulaciones más estrictas de europa
en prácticamente todos los mercados pues
eso también afecta al mercado de los
alquileres
[Música]
si alguno de vosotros ha vivido en parís
lo sabe muy bien es prácticamente
imposible encontrar un piso en esta
ciudad e incluso los trabajadores bien
pagados que llegan a la ciudad
contratados por una multinacional
terminan en casas viejas pequeñas y
tremendamente caras según expat instant
puntocom alquilar un piso de 45 metros
cuadrados en un barrio normal de parís
cuesta unos 1200 euros al mes es el
mismo precio que en una ciudad como
munich la diferencia pues que parís
tiene un paro del 8 por ciento y munich
un paro del 2 por ciento sin esos expats
que trabajan en multinacionales se
quejan de la vivienda imaginad a
nuestros amigos
ahmed y hassan que están en el paro
conclusión
bienvenido a tu nuevo hogar en los
barrios marginales de parís cerca de la
estación de metro de stalingrado
encontrarás la chabola con la que
siempre has soñado a coste cero
zonas verdes con los mejores
narcotraficantes de la ciudad
actividades de ocio para toda la familia
y las mejores mezquitas a las pistas
patrocinadas por nuestros amigos de
arabia saudita
barrios marginales de parís nueva vida
te está esperando
y qué pasa dentro de estos barrios
marginales pues ahora mismo lo vamos a
ver
la reducción del radicalismo muchos
pensaréis que islam radical es una
vuelta a la edad media una ideología
ultraconservadora y ultra religiosa
verdad error craso error la ideología
que profesa la mayor parte de los
radicales islámicos en francia es el
salafismo el salafismo nacional siglo 18
en lo que ahora es arabia saudita pero
fue en los años 60 del siglo 20 cuando
se convirtió en el movimiento religioso
mayoritario de este país por esos
momentos arabia saudita ya se había
convertido en la petro monarquía quienes
hoy en día
desde entonces el dinero del zumo de
dinosaurio ha financiado la construcción
de mezquitas y escuelas islámicas por
todo el mundo
y esto explica que el salafismo esté
ganando terreno al resto de confesiones
islámicas por ejemplo recordáis al
profesor asesinado samuel para ti pues
su asesino venía de chechenia
profesionalmente la religión mayoritaria
en chechenia y daguestán era el islam
sufí sin embargo en los últimos años el
salafismo ha ido ganando terreno y algo
parecido ocurre en francia en el año
2004 ya había más de 5000 salafistas en
el país éstos salafistas estaban
concentrados principalmente en los
barrios marginales y esto explica
noticias como esta
la revuelta de inmigrantes incendia en
francia por novena noche consecutiva
exacto en el año 2005 francia sufrió
unas revueltas que se prolongaron por
tres semanas dos civiles asesinados y
8.000 coches incendiados y es en ese
momento cuando francia se dio cuenta de
que tenía un problema y cuál diría es
que fue la solución pues atentos
[Música]
el consejo francés para la fe musulmana
crea un consejo teológico para frenar el
discurso radical exacto para frenar el
avance del islam radical francia creó un
órgano gubernamental para comunicarse
con la comunidad musulmana
la idea era promover una versión del
islam compatible con la democracia
aunque algunos críticos dirían que más
bien lo que francia intentaba era
diseñar su propia versión del islam
desde el estado y os preguntaréis
funcionado este consejo pues juzgar por
vosotros mismos en 2005 francia tenía
alrededor de 5000 salafistas en 2010
eran más de 12.000 y a día de hoy se
habla de entre 30.000 y 50.000
salafistas eso por no hablar de todos
los atentados terroristas que han
asolado el país desde entonces
y diréis vale entonces cuál es la
solución pues lo cierto es que a día de
hoy se sabe muy poco sobre cómo evitar
la radicalización que hay algo
controvertido en este mundo es la
política antiterrorista y hay toda clase
de soluciones sobre la mesa en arabia
saudita han llegado a crear centros de
de radicalización que imitan los métodos
para rehabilitar a los drogadictos
hablaremos de ellos en próximos vídeos
los terroristas hacen cosas como arte
terapia dinámicas de grupos y cosas
parecidas el resultado pues alguna
gobierno saudí es un éxito pero la
realidad es que ya hay más de 50 casos
de personas supuestamente de
radicalizadas que han vuelto cometer
atentados
[Música]
en algunas universidades de españa y de
california han llegado a hacer escáneres
cerebrales de terroristas para entender
qué tipo de mensajes podrían servir para
de radicalizar a un potencial terrorista
el tema de la radicalización y la
desradicalización es tan complejo que
daría para un vídeo en sí mismo así que
vamos a limitarnos a contar lo que ha
propuesto en manuel patrones
[Música]
la cruzada contra el separatismo
islámico a estas alturas podemos decir
que uno de los principales factores del
radicalismo son las mezquitas y escuelas
radicales y la mayor parte de esas
mezquitas están pagadas con dinero que
viene del extranjero sin embargo si
buscáis en google apenas encontrareis un
registro concreto de quién ha pagado que
por qué pues porque a diferencia de las
empresas las religiones no tienen que
publicar sus libros de cuentas en ningún
sitio al igual que las ongs las
organizaciones religiosas están exentas
de pagar impuestos así que los
inspectores de hacienda no tienen que
investigarlas
a eso hay que sumarle otro factor
importante el salafismo no es una
religión jerárquica es decir que a
diferencia del catolicismo no existe un
papá del salafismo ni nada que se le
parezca es más cuando decimos que arabia
saudita ha financiado la construcción de
una mezquita no nos referimos al
gobierno de este país en la mayor parte
de los casos son grupos privados
[Música]
pensando bien basta con que un grupo de
millonarios saudíes hagan una
transferencia a unos voluntarios a
instancias para que se puedan construir
una mezquita conclusión es prácticamente
imposible saber dónde se está
promoviendo el radicalismo y por eso el
plan de macrón consiste en hacer un
registro nacional con todos los lugares
de culto islámico saber de dónde viene
la financiación y saber qué tipo de
ideas promueven los queridos demás
macrón también quiere prohibir el
homeschooling de esta forma garantiza
que todos los niños y niñas francesas
reciben la misma educación y esto es lo
que ha generado las críticas de líderes
como el presidente de turquía
[Música]
dice que los musulmanes en europa están
siendo tratados como los judíos antes de
la segunda guerra mundial si lleváis
tiempo suscritos a visual político ya
sabéis que la gran aspiración de erdogán
es ampliar su cuota de influencia en
todo el mundo islámico este tipo de
declaraciones van en esa línea creo que
no hace falta decir que la comparación
es completamente absurda pero lo cierto
es que erdogán no ha sido el único líder
en criticar el plan de macrón atentos a
lo que ha dicho el presidente de
pakistán
camps y de los países musulmanes que
confronten colectivamente la tendencia
de islamofobia en los países europeos
concretamente en el discurso que dio el
presidente de pakistán las caricaturas
de mahoma contarían como discurso de
odio es decir que según este hombre la
libertad de expresión no contempla la
blasfemia es comprensible que piensa así
a fin de cuentas en pakistán llevan
varios años sin saber lo que es la
libertad de expresión sin ir más lejos
este vídeo no se podría ver desde
pakistán porque pues porque youtube está
prohibido en todo el país y lo mismo
ocurre con tip top y todas las páginas
de no por pero esperad un momento porque
ya me puedo imaginar lo que estará
pensando alguno esto es una guerra entre
los valores occidentales y los valores
islámicos sin embargo conviene recordar
que muchos líderes occidentales también
estarían de acuerdo con mucho de lo que
ha dicho el presidente de pakistán
atentos a lo que dijo el papá francisco
días después de los atentados de charly
en popa
[Música]
no se puede provocar no se puede
insultar a otras creencias de la gente
uno no puede burlarse de la gente uno no
puede burlarse de la fe el doctor gaspar
y mi gran amigo dice una mala palabra
contra mi madre él espera un puñetazo a
la campaña llegados a este punto creo
que es importante dejar una cosa muy
clara la libertad de expresión si
contemplan la blasfemia la sátira y los
insultos contra cualquier religión ahí
está el caso de slayer marilyn manson o
vimos artistas que han hecho toda una
carrera basándose en la blasfemia todos
hemos visto películas como la vida de
brian o series de televisión que hacen
todo tipo de sátira religiosas todo eso
está o debería estar perfectamente
contemplado por la libertad de expresión
nadie debería tener miedo de que les
vayan a matar por criticar o por hacer
sátira de una religión o de una
ideología política pero esperad un
momento porque el hecho de que erdogán
frank al presidente de pakistán se
equivoquen no significa que el plan de
macrón sea perfecto en realidad hay
muchas críticas legítimas que se pueden
hacer a este registro de mezquitas que
quiere hacer francia y por eso ahora es
cuando vamos a abrir
el debate os parece bien que el estado
regule las religiones creéis que el plan
de macrón va a solucionar el problema
del separatismo islámico podéis dejarme
vuestra respuesta en los comentarios y
como siempre no olvidéis que sacamos
vídeos nuevos todas las semanas así que
suscribe os aviso al político y darle a
la campanita para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones si os ha
gustado este vídeo dadle a like y nos
vemos en el próximo un abrazo y hasta
pronto
[Música]